well Virginia Patrol Marquis is a
journalist with Al Jazeera online and as
recently you've just returned from the
refugee camps in Chad um thank you very
much for joining us on the set
um can you just tell us a little bit
about what you saw in these refugee
camps and and I guess the conditions
that they are facing there
yeah I mean the conditioner absolutely
dire I mean as just you mentioned there
are a hundred thousand people who
actually fled violence from Sudan um
specifically Darfur in the case of Chad
they have absolutely nothing like you
name it water toilet shelters they need
everything possible imaginable and we
have been talking with women who had
barely been able to fed their children
for days we're talking about a woman who
fled her Village after her husband was
shot dead in front of her and she was
able to just get you know one blanket
for her three children so these are the
kind of refugees you see who literally
fled in a state of absolute emergency
and immediately without any warning and
I mean the U.N are of course doing as
much as they can wfp has been able to
give some rationing for about 50 000
people but they can do that only for a
month now they need fundings for the
next six months the unhcr is also
working around the clock to provide
first aid humanitarian aid but of course
they have another logistical challenge
which is to relocate all these hundred
thousand deeper into the country and
this is for two main reasons one is
security because fighting is still
ongoing along the border and you're
literally there and you hear gunfire
just across the border for how close you
are yeah yeah and then sorry and the
last reason is due to rain season which
is due to starting four weeks time and
by then whoever is gonna be along the
border is going to be completely
isolated due to Rivers which are gonna
form on that side and I guess before
they even get there there's the journey
from that I've had to make from Sudan
can you tell us a bit about some of the
stories you heard about you know them
trying to escape the fighting yeah well
so that's a pretty another Grim story or
these a hundred thousand we know that
ninety percent are women and children
and that already tells you a pretty Grim
story because this the absence of men in
the camps it's pretty uh unsettling and
we know we have heard that this is
because they have been left behind
either or to protect the land or to
fight so escaping is not not everybody
managed to escape either because they
stayed or they or because they couldn't
and the other problem is that there are
we know that there is a complete
communication blackout from certain city
in Western four specifically El Janina
the capital it's at least since May 19
that we have barely any information from
there and we have heard accounts of
people who literally escaped us thanks
to us Smuggler who bring them and
they're just running escaping literally
gunfire behind them what about some of
the accounts that you heard about the
situation in Darfur whether violence is
I guess taken on a slightly different
dimension hasn't it yeah yeah I mean as
you mentioned uh fighting in there for
has taken its own Dimension definitely
there are cities where the confrontation
is between the Army and your rapid
support forces but in many villages and
in many other towns the confrontation is
actually between Arab armed men and
non-arable communities now this is a
sort of Confrontation that has been
ongoing for a long time due to the
competition over water and land
resources mostly but that has taken a
pretty Grim turn and we have heard
hiring accounts about the fighting
between these two communities with the
Arab militia with the upper hand much
more well equipped and armed I mean we
have heard reports from elginina people
50 families hiding inside one apartment
running from one room to another one to
escape bullets because they don't know
and they have to take turns to go and
fetch water once at a time because you
know it can be yeah the last time just
some horrific stories coming out of
Sudan thank you so much um for your
reporting but also for coming in and
telling us your experiences and Chad
that's Virginia Marquis a journalist
with Al jazeer digital thank you thank
you well you can read Virginia's full
report on our website uh there it is
that's Al jazeera.com